elabora la gráfica de la ecuación lineal
5 x 2 igual a 20 básicamente queremos
graficar la recta que es el conjunto de
coordenadas el conjunto de puntos xy que
cumplen con esta ecuación lineal para
esto simplemente vamos a elaborar una
tabla con valores de x y los valores de
ye correspondientes que cumplen con esta
relación para facilitar esto puede
despejar allí de la ecuación y así
fácilmente dados los valores de x
obtendremos los valores de y tenemos
entonces 5x + 2 igual a 20 queremos
despejar y así es que vamos a restar 5x
ambos lados de la ecuación menos 5x del
lado izquierdo y menos 5x del lado
derecho estos términos se cancelan nos
quedan 2 y del lado izquierdo y del lado
derecho nos queda 20 menos 5x
ahora vamos a dividir entre 2 ambos
lados de la ecuación dividimos entre 2
el lado izquierdo y entre 2 el lado
derecho estos términos se van nos queda
del lado izquierdo y del lado derecho
podemos dejarlo ya así sería más fácil
calcularlo pero bueno vamos a
simplificarlo entonces sería 20 entre 2
es igual a 10
los 50 y 25 medios de x ahora sí ya
podemos ir dando valores de x obtener
los valores de iu y simplemente graficar
los déjame hacer esto en un color
distinto voy a agarrar este que es otro
tono de amarillo tenemos entonces
valores para x
valores para ello empecemos con x igual
a 0 podría ser cualquier valor pero con
x igual a 0 es más fácil calcular el
valor de y con x igual a 0 cuánto vale
ya lleva a ser igual a 10 menos 5 medios
de cero y esto va a ser igual 5 medios
de cero es 0 y nos queda de igual a 10
así es que cuando x vale cero cuando x
vale cero y vale diez hemos obtenido el
punto 0,10 vamos a graficar lo x igual a
cero es justo en el centro del eje x y
10 para la coordenada n 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 0 10 es este punto de aquí 0,10
encontremos otro punto vamos a agarrar
para x igual a 2 fue agarrar múltiplos
de 2 para que éstos simplifique en un
número entero entonces para x igualados
lleva a ser igual a 10 menos 5 medios de
2 aquí tenemos dos en el denominador y 2
en el numerador se simplifican y nos
queda simplemente 10 5 es igual a 5 es
decir hemos hallado en el punto 252 para
la x 5 para de ayer vamos a graficar lo
entonces tenemos 2 para la x 12 justo
aquí y ya igual 5 hacia arriba 1 2 3 4 5
este es el punto 2,5 y para graficar una
recta sólo necesitamos 2 puntos
usando una regla podemos trazar la recta
que pasa a través de estos dos puntos si
la trazamos con cuidado cada punto en
esa línea satisface esta relación
simplemente para practicar obtendré más
puntos haciendo ahora x igual a 4
obtenemos que ya es igual a 10 menos 5
medios de 4 y esto que es igual
bueno aquí podemos simplificar tenemos 2
en el denominador 4 el numerador este 2
2 entre 2 es igual a 14 entre 2 es igual
a 2 y nos queda entonces 10 menos 5 por
25 por 12 10 10 menos 10 es igual a 0
hemos obtenido el punto 40 tenemos
entonces para x 1 2 3 4 4 para x y la 0
el punto está sobre el eje x este es el
punto 4,0 y puedo obtener otros puntos
puedes hacerlo por tu cuenta si lo
deseas pero con estos 3 puntos es más
que suficiente de hecho con sólo dos
puntos bastaba para trazar la red
así es que déjame graficar para esto voy
a usar el blanco la línea se verá la
línea se verá algo como esto la línea se
verá algo más o menos como esto esta es
la apariencia de la línea y podría
extenderla a ambas direcciones y aquí la
tienes
esta es la gráfica de la ecuación lineal
déjame resaltar la línea me parece que
me queda un poco delgada la voy a
resaltar para que puedas ver más
claramente la gráfica de esta recta